You know, what kinds of operations
do you want to do on binary images?
So, you know, often what you
want to do is you want to separate
objects one from another, that
are sort of accidentally touching, and
you want to collect together pixels
that all belong to the same object.
And then another thing you might
want to do is compute the features
of a binary object.
And we actually did this also.
Remember we talked about hue moments,
and we were talking about
moments in general?
And moments are a descriptor of
the shape of a binary patch.
And so, again, those are things
that you would do on binary images.
So here's an example.
This was a thresholded,
red blood cell image.
And by the way in the old days,
not so old, in fact mom, sorry.
My mother, I think her first job out
of college was as a medical technician.
One of the things you had to do
was count white blood cells in a,
under a microscope and for a certain
amount, and you would count the density.
Actually, people sometimes
still do that, even today.
But what you'd really like to be
able to do is spread out a bunch of
blood cells and
have a machine do the counting.
How many red blood cells?
How many white blood cells?
Especially, if instead of just
doing a patient at a time,
you were doing a massive study, and
you had tens of thousands of
samples you wanted counted, right?
So, here's an example of taking
an image, thresholding it.
And, you know,
if I were to ask you to count how
many red blood cells there were,
you could probably find all of the, well
let's start with one that's easy, right?
You say a-ha, here's one that's
pretty separated, no problem,
here's another one.
Oh, but this is a weird one,
look at that.
It's got a hole in it and here are two,
those are probably two, right?
But it's one blob
connected by a thin thing.
So you'd really like to be able to
take this image and then fix it up.
You know, because, in this particular
image, there was 63 separate
objects detected and a normal blood
cell has an area of about a 50.
But you'll notice there are some things
here, where obviously there were
things that were touching each other
that were counted as single cells,
when actually, they were gobs.
And then there were things
that were really small, right?
And so here, they were just using
the number to determine which kinds of
things are cells.
And what you'd like to do is you'd like
to be able to separate out each one of
those cells.
So, we're going to do some binary
image operations to do that.
And what kind of operations are there?
Well, first one we're going to talk
just a little bit about is thresholding.
because in some sense, in order to get
a binary image, you have to go from
a color or a gray-scale image
that has continuous values or,
lots of values to something that
just has two zero and ones.
So determining a threshold
is always a challenge.
Then, what you'd like to do is you'd
like to find all the pixels that
are connected.
And that's called connected
components analysis, and we'll,
we'll talk about that, that one's used
a lot also to find independent blobs.
And then you want to sometimes
improve those blobs, and
that's referred to as morphology, and
we're going to talk about a variety of
morphological operators, including
some of the more important ones.
Then once you've done all that,
then you may compute some features
on those blobs,
like I was talking about before.
Moments, areas, these kinds of things.